No loop, no loop, guys.
Sorry, I'm just, I'm all over the place right now.
There's so much stuff to do, there's only one dokey.
Hello, I'm sorry for a super late night.
I mean, this could have been a good night dragons, but my
thumbnail maker was not awake at that time.
She's awake now, but they were not awake, and I didn't
really want to...
I don't know.
It's gonna look really scuffed, so I was just like, Late
Night Hangout!
Because you can tell which thumbnail is made by me, and
which thumbnail is made by my thumbnail maker.
It's sort of, you sort of tell.
I don't know how you can tell, but there is a way to figure
out which one is a dokey thumbnail, and which one is a
thumbnail, a person who is paid to make thumbnails
thumbnail.
It's, it's, it's, it's like a little hint, you know, there's
like a little, um, you sort of tell, there's like a little
hint when you tell which one's mine and which one's hers.
Uh, a little sign there.
Uh, hello everybody.
I am taking a little break from, um, Hell Week right now to
hang out with you guys.
Uh, sorry for the, for the late ish, well, it is pretty late
schedule.
I was, I literally woke up.
at 4pm.
I didn't do anything for Canada Day.
I was just like, what do I...
Well, I can't just post Happy Canada Day.
So I was like, alright, I'm gonna...
I'm just gonna take a picture of Dad, because he was really
cute and he, like, was sleeping.
And I was just like, I'll take a picture of him.
And then he'll be my model for today.
He's like, Happy Canada Day.
I didn't do anything for Canada Day.
Yes, it's still Canada Day.
We have two more hours of Canada Day here in West Coast.
Um...
I didn't do anything for Canada Day because I feel like for
Canada Day a lot of stuff events and stuff I realized for
Canada Day is geared towards families it's for like families
especially families with children so like because the last
time I did something for Canada Day it was me lining up at a
food truck for an hour for a fucking overpriced sandwich and
then going home so so I was just like not again I'm not
never again so I learned my lesson because like okay so like
Canada around here it's it's literally just like it's just
food it's just food trucks and all And like, I guess, I
don't know, like musical performances and vibing and just
hanging out.
But now it's just like, I don't really want to like go
outside and listen, like just go outside and like line up
for overpriced food.
Like, I'm going to do that in LA anyway.
So I was just like, why should I do that in Canada?
I might as well just sleep in.
Oh, there's going to be fireworks.
Also, there was like, apparently there was like something
that there's gonna be fireworks like soon-ish So we might
hear I don't know my mic's gonna pick up on fireworks.
Yeah, and then but yeah, it's because I was thinking I'm
gonna be doing that anyway when I'm going to LA so I might
as well save my money on Canada Day and then go buy
overpriced food in LA
so so as i i didn't do anything on calendar day i was most i
mostly just um i was also so tired i think i slept like 11
hours today um well uh or maybe oh wait it's already 10
you're right maybe the fireworks already went off maybe
there's no fireworks near me i don't fucking know honestly
um i still no it's because like right after the mexico game
um i disassociated for like 30 minutes and then i uh because
i didn't want to keep matara up for too long because she had
something to do in the morning today like she had to wake up
at like eight in the eight in the morning today so so i
didn't want to keep her up for too long so i just
disassociated for 30 minutes right after stream and then uh
i uh i i called matara and then we had to do a recording
session like we did four to five hour recordings recordings
to be fair the recordings itself is not four to five hours
it's just that um in between recordings we kept on talking
we were just hanging out and just we just kept on yapping
and everything so it became a four to five hour call um so
then after that i literally like passed out afterwards uh um
in bed and i woke up i woke up to i think like yeah i i oh
yeah no afterwards i before i passed out i walked dad just
in case i passed out for too long so i like had some
precautions you know just in case i passed up for too long
at least dad peed and pooped so i'm So, so yeah, I'm glad I
did because I ended up sleeping for 11 hours.
Yeah, so, um, so I was so tired.
So I woke up around four, four-ish, because I was like, I
was like, oh, I'm gonna wake up early.
I'm gonna like take a little bit of a little nappy poo and
then like do my schedule and then like maybe I'll take a nap
for my stream today.
And that didn't happen.
I didn't set alarm because I was like, I don't know if I'm
gonna be streaming today.
the day because um i will be gone um i'll be gone uh in la
uh for not for a while like it's just be like for a couple
of days so i do want to like get some streams in before
because i don't know what the internet situation is gonna be
like in la i might have to buy like a internet card or
something like a like a wi-fi like i don't know like like
you know how the i uh the irl streamers they have like this
like portable router some shit so i might buy like a
portable router and then like uh and then use that to stream
but i'm also on a laptop so i'm very constrained with what i
can stream so i don't want to like i don't want to like uh
yeah like a little hotspot thing but i also don't want to uh
i don't want to like uh just stay inside and stream as well
while i'm at la like LA I'm sorry like LA is already more
expensive than what LA should like LA is expensive but LA
this week on this week on my birthday is even more expensive
so so I was just like guys guys I'm sorry if I don't if I
only stream one time when I'm in LA I'm sorry because I'm
like I'm I paid so much to be here.
I might as well do something.
I Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Aren't you being paid for like, I think I spent all my
concert money already for the concert.
Like, I, I, I, I think I'm losing money only because I'm,
for those who are like, how are you losing money?
Yeah, because I want to make it really, really good concert
experience for all of you guys so i paid for i told you guys
it's two new 3d outfits for the concert and that is not
cheap that so the concert is debuting two outfit two new 3d
outfits so you guys are gonna get a quite a nice surprise
yes i told you guys I already told you guys it was going to
be two.
Guys, why are you so surprised?
Why are you so surprised?
I already told you guys.
Yes, I did.
I remembered.
Yes, I can't gaslight me.
You can't gaslight me.
I already said it.
You can't gaslight me, guys.
Unless I'm gaslighting you.
Did you tell us in a dream?
You never.
Anyway, it's two.
I think I'll break even.
I'll break even.
But I'm not doing this for profit, though.
I'm not doing these concerts.
I mean, it was more so like I want you guys to have...
a great experience.
Yeah, I might be exaggerating, guys.
I might be exaggerating.
But I did invest a lot of money into the concert because I
want you guys to have a great experience and have a great
time, especially for those also who are watching via the
streaming tickets, by the way.
For those who can't make it as well.
And I want you guys to also have a great time watching via
the streaming ticket and everything.
I think the merch store is going to be out tomorrow for the
concert merch.
A little bit of a little pre, like a little spoiler update
regarding it.
Next, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You teased the second outfit, but I'm not sure you made it
clear.
It was a second three outfit for the concert.
See?
I knew it!
Nexy has my back.
See?
You guys try to gaslight me.
I'm like, I knew it.
You can't gaslight me.
I gaslight you.
Nexy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Solid.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, technically it's three.
If we count the outfit from the concert, like the concert
key visual.
Technically, it's three because of the concert key visual.
Solid Snake, thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
Paid chatter.
No, uh-uh.
If anything, she paid me on Paid Streamer.
Paid Streamer.
Solid Snake.
you in the super chat thank you thank you um you didn't tell
us about the outfits not that you're technically in the
negative that's just me exaggerated i just know i spent a
lot of money i think uh my hopes is that i don't go negative
because of how much i invested into the concert i i invested
a lot into the concert because i wanted you guys to have um
a great experience with
in a lot like I even had like booked like extra days at the
3d mocap studio as well for like when I was like trying to
like test stuff out and everything and like testing out the
dancing and stuff so like I had to when I wanted to practice
dancing and stuff I had to book an extra day at the studio
just to see if it all turned out okay during rehearsals and
stuff Because I know you guys remember when I, like, had to
travel and stuff, too.
So, yeah.
So, because, like, I had...
There was no...
And then dance.
Oh, my God.
The dances.
The dancing.
It's so...
Oh, and the dance lessons, too.
So, I invested...
I invested a lot into the concert.
So, I hope I...
I don't really...
I'm not, like, looking at the money too much.
I just want you guys to have a great experience.
So like my hopes is just you guys having a great experience,
whether or not like I, whether or not I lost money doing the
concert, or I break even or I make profit.
My biggest, my biggest hope is for you guys to have lots of
fun there.
Like even like I think like last week I spent money, a lot
of money on something to make the concert even better.
I might have had something funny.
Okay, but this will only be for the people at the venue.
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry.
You guys might not be able to see it.
For those who have the streaming tickets, but the people at
the venue, you guys get a little bit something extra special
that I spent money on, like, last week for it.
but but uh people who are not there at the venue maybe
someone will record it because i will say um um when people
at the venue they will know they will know and i give you
guys permission to record that part.
I'll give you guys permission to record, because I even say,
I, okay, I even say it in the thing, too, but like, I'll, I,
just that one part.
That one part.
Everybody, thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
You have a PO box?
I want to send you a book.
Do you get... I do!
It's on Twitter!
Um, you click on the schedule.
It does say where my PO box is.
By the way, for this or don't know of her going to the
concert, you can give me gifts and letters, and then my
staff will screen it, and then give it to me, because I will
be there, obviously, because I have to perform!
Yeah!
Um, yeah, I won't record it, but we won't share.
I'm super excited.
I think I'm more excited about just shopping at Animix.
Actually, no.
I'm equally excited about shopping at anime expo i don't
think i'm gonna be able to walk on do the entire and i don't
think i'll be able to see the entire anime expo because i
only have like a limited time because like i'm gonna go to
i'm gonna like i'm gonna like have a limited time just
walking around anime expo so i hope that i can enjoy um as
much as i can and buy as much as i can there i'm gonna of
money just for uh just to shop i need a new wardrobe oh so
my favorite artist like artists apparel artists are there uh
so oh my gosh let me see if i saved it um but yeah that's
why also that's why i am here late at night so i can take a
little break hang out with all of you guys oh wait i wish
happy birthday with somebody's birthday well they go super
chat thank you thank you July 3rd, March my one year dragon
anniversary, and my birthday!
I'll be at AX and attending the meet and greet.
Oh my god, can't wait to see you there, Quill!
But can I be a greeting and ask for an early happy birthday?
Of course you can!
Happy birthday to you, happy birthday to you, happy
birthday, dear Quill!
Happy birthday to you, yeah!
Happy birthday!
thank you guys and now I only have a great birthday on July
3rd and I hope you feel that's a panel tool oh yeah by the
way I um um I like I could have easily just uh not spend a
lot of fucking money on the the two new on the two new uh
two new 3d models but but I want to to I wanted to because
like I said like a concert is a whole new experience you've
already seen me dancing in the bounty hunter outfit you've
already seen me dancing in the retro doki outfit I want you
guys to see me dancing you paid so much you guys you guys
paid so much money for those who are traveling to LA during
World Cup and also America's birthday for some reason was
celebrating at the same time as me like oh my god I was here
first during America's us 250th birthday um i'm 251 like um
and i wanted to give you guys a whole new experience and
also like for those who are paying for the streaming tickets
as well i want you guys to have a wonderful experience with
like new shiny stuff and everything you know um that's why
uh i that's why like i spent so i invested so much into the
concert because Like I said, you already see me dancing in
all those other outfits.
Why don't you see me dancing in something new and improved?
So yeah.
Yeah.
Anyway, you guys can see my streaming tickets.
It might be in person.
Might be sold out.
But you can still buy the streaming tickets.
Yeah.
All right, let's see.
I mean, I'm super excited, though.
I can't believe we have, like, what?
It's, like, in three more days.
So, I'm very, very excited.
It's so soon.
I have, like, 800 million tabs right now.
It's actually crazy.
Like, my tabs are so tiny.
I have two browsers with 200 million tabs.
But, yes, even in the stream, I think the stream, preview
the free stream preview um it'll showcase both both the new
outfits so
yeah so you guys don't have to worry for those who are like
oh no paywag no no no no no no no no no it'll both be
they'll both be showcased in the free streaming preview so
you don't have to worry about that.
I hope me spoiling that doesn't kill the hype, guys.
I'm sorry.
I don't know.
I did realize I thought I knew I mentioned it, but you guys
just didn't remember.
I hope it builds up more excitement, guys.
More excitement about the concert instead of being like, oh,
She's debuting new...
Yeah, I'm not gonna watch now.
Now I'm not...
Yeah, I was like...
You're like, oh, man.
Now I don't wanna watch.
Now that I know what the surprise is.
Wow, dude.
I wanna be pleasantly surprised.
And now you ruined it for me.
Ew.
new stuff this guy I wanted to go and watch bounty hunter
dokey two is too many god dokey how am I be right back
canceling my tickets you ruined it you didn't ruin I just
wanted one new outfit not to now that's just too many that's
has way too many my surprise is ruined we don't like change
might as well post the entire set list as well dokey um
lobster to butter steak to juicy uh lali thank you super
chat thank you late happy canada day you super chat thank
you thank you papa smurfing thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you i saw an artist with daft punk uh merch
here's an advance oh i can't wait i cannot wait i hope i'll
be able to like look at all i know my feet's gonna fucking
kill me i i know i'm gonna fight i know my feet's gonna be
so sore at the end of it uh might as well make it all free
don't you ruin the surprise um Alright, oh yeah, uh, let me
go grab some water real quick.
I'll be right back.
I forgot to refill my water bottle.
I'll be right back, guys.
Alright, I am back.
Rice, Nexy, Solid, Quill.
Thank you, thank you.
Lair Bear, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Um, and it's just you feel like giving the estimate we
should bring for the merch at the Contrast to those of us
going to XAX the day before.
uh save enough um all right if you want to buy the full set
yeah i'll let you guys know let me look at the price it was
supposed to be posted yesterday oh yeah the little spoiler
thing for it so um this will be an on there's an on venue
exclusive and an online exclusive merch the reason why we
have an online exclusive merch is that we couldn't get that
particular merch made in time for the venue so um people and
it's very small it's very small by the way um i just say
it's stickers because it was a it was a last minute edition
from me um that i wanted to add stickers um of the chibi art
um that has not been revealed yet so that's an online
exclusive um just because we weren't able to get it main in
time and so um this is the only way you can get like the
only way to get is through the online web store but they're
just stickers so shipping won't shouldn't I hope shipping
won't be that expensive um but I did want to um add it in
because there was no way to get the cheapy art in our other
merch lineup um there was okay there was a way it was but it
was like super I will say it was like it wasn't like the
full artwork so i wanted to have a chat i added this last
minute because i was like i want people to have a chance to
have the full artwork artwork if they want to you know like
oh because there is there are other merch with the chibi art
but it wasn't like the full artwork itself it was like a
little bit cropped off and everything so i wanted a way for
you guys to own the full artwork but only if you guys want
to so it's like so that's why it's an online exclusive the
stickers um and it's just like but anyway for the other
merch i will say uh let me calculate this um so stickers
won't be available on at the venue but uh it will be uh
there you can get it online all the other merch are is
available at the venue and they there is one venue exclusive
merch Um, there, I believe in total for the venue.
If you want to buy everything, it will be around $150.
If you want to buy everything at the venue.
Um, so, but yeah, that's really all I can say.
For everything, yeah.
And it's like.
six items yeah it's six items if you want to buy everything
yes USD I'm talking about USD I can't say what everything
includes guys unless no I can't already spoiled a lot of
stuff I don't even know me spoiling about the new outfits
was or not I don't know I don't know I'm just I was like oh
shit should I have said that
hey sir thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
happy Canada day toky uh yeah I know I told you guys I
remember it I told you guys but you guys were like I didn't
hear but I was like taking talking about it
but still good luck with concert have a great time in LA
don't go broke on food and shopping thank you that's super
chat thank you thank you well luckily luckily my birthday is
also when I'm in LA yeah so I can get birthday money
um can you do it I I will say I might have done it during
rehearsal.
I know I did.
I just haven't got the recording of it yet.
Yavi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I also did the cha-cha slide.
Maybe those, I haven't got it yet.
But I did, I haven't got the data when I was like rehearsing
and stuff.
So I might have done the cha-cha slide.
Slide to the left.
That's not spoilers for the concert.
That's just me fucking around in motion capture.
Slide to the right.
Two hops this time.
Yeah, cha-cha slide.
I did a cha-cha slide and I did I did Soldier Boy again.
And then, like, just for fun, I know, like, I don't need it,
but I just did.
I have to clap your hands.
Okay.
Chris Cross!
Alan, they give a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Talking about outfits.
We pay to have the Chinese New Year's one as a normal one.
Name your price.
You don't even have to pay.
What was I going to say?
I do hope you guys like...
Oh, yeah.
guys were like, oh, that's not too, I did lower the price of
it for like, guys, remember I told you guys, like one of the
reasons why the merch store the merch store took a lot, the
sorry, the the dokey dokey rewind time merch stuff isn't up
yet is because I also negotiated the prices lower because I
thought it was a little too pricey.
So they took like five to $10 off of each item for me just
because I want to make it more affordable.
I don't mind like making less profit because you know, I
know like what's going, like, you know, the economy and
everything and the fact that LA is very fucking expensive
right now.
So I was just like, these seem a little bit too expensive.
So I was like, could you guys lower it like by a little bit
more just because like I do want it to be affordable for
everybody who's ordering the merch either online, on in
venue as well so um the price uh i already tried my best to
make it affordable for you guys so i hope you guys like the
merch when it's posted tomorrow i think maybe i think
uh so yeah uh i hope you guys like the merch because um i
had a lot of input and what i wanted uh for the merch store
uh and um it's all creative ideas out there
originally you know it was the usual stuff wait let me see
what they originally this was what they proposed and i was
like no i was like i don't want that so let me see uh let me
see i i think i still yeah i still have i still have like
the the spreadsheet of what they won originally oh okay it
was like um one of the things I changed was uh an acrylic
stand and like just uh like t-shirts and hoodies and I was
like I felt like that was a little boring because uh but
they had two other suggestions they had another suggestion I
was like I two other suggestions that I suggested that they
kept in the merchandise all the merch in there was like my
idea on what I want for my for the merch lineup so but like
there's two of them that I removed because I felt like it
was very I just I like unique stuff you know like so I like
unique stuff I like to have like unique merch and stuff and
like have fun within everything um you know i don't want you
guys to get like the 200th acrylic standee uh or like more
hoodies and more t-shirt like okay it's i we have apparel
but um they wanted like hoodies and t-shirts i said we
should just pick one because like i didn't want to reuse a
lot of the artwork too especially this apparel i just didn't
want to reuse it so i said we'll choose one of the apparel
and then we're going to focus on like more unique merch
stuff if we have to reuse the illustrations at least it's a
new a new merch thing for it not just like colic sandy or
anything um so so i'm really looking forward to showing guys
what they are uh and it's like very and it's very like a
very what is it very western rock concert theme type of
merch Alec, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Alec, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hello, first time super chatting.
Wanted to support you before heading back to do some more
open Utah stuff.
Anyways, have a good night or day out now.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Good luck at what's open Utah?
Open Utah.
But thank you so much for your very, first super chat what
is that it's not a design open source successor oh is it
wait is it like is that vocaloid
is that vocaloid related i think it was super chat thank you
thank you also yeah thank you again for yes but for oh good
luck good luck wait is it actually though like the store
is...
Okay, let me check.
Because I don't want to talk about it.
They haven't, uh, said anything.
And so I was just like...
Let's see.
Oh!
Wait.
I mean, let me act them.
Uh...
I don't even know if...
Okay.
I'm adding the tag
Whoops Well, I didn't leak it Hey guys Billy, thank you for
the five Give the chips, thank you, thank you Old man, thank
you for the Super Chat, thank you, thank you Don't keep
article merch In the future would be Thank you for the super
chat, thank you, thank you.
Yay, I can talk about it.
They're like, go for it.
All right, this entire stream is just a spoiler stream.
Let the floodgates open.
Like behind the scene leaks right now.
There's a paparazzi.
I got the deeps, guys.
We're leaking it all.
So, I mean, if it's up, I might as well fucking show it to
you guys.
So, I'll wait until I'll like tweet about it when it's like
up on the...
They said that the producers said I can.
So, well, might as well.
Spoiler warning.
Alright.
Bam!
So, yeah, all right, so I'm starting to finally actually, so
the dokey dokey rewind, I'll do it one by one, I'm gonna,
all right, so you guys see, for the t-shirts, for the
t-shirts, I want it to be like a concert t-shirt, so you
guys can see there's like, okay, wait, let me, I'll do like
a tiny thing, so you guys can see all of it, so yes, the pen
lights are venue exclusive, but your online exclusive, is,
yes, I, that's, I, I, I demanded to have a tech deck.
I, I was like, I need a finger skate boy.
But Doki wears the dog shirts.
So, so the tech deck was like the one thing I hard pushed
for because I felt like, like, I felt like it fit the theme.
Like I said, the merch itself, you remember what I said, the
merch I tried to push for?
It's very westernized concert merch type feel, like what you
can see.
Like it's like 2000s, 2010s type of merch.
And like I hard pushed for stuff like that.
So you can see like, you know, there's the tech deck.
There's the sweat band.
There's the guitar pick set.
There's the CD keychain.
And the concert t-shirt.
So like the concert t-shirt, I tried to make it look like an
actual concert t-shirt and everything.
The one thing I'm sad that we couldn't get made were like
concert posters.
But like we felt like it was just, Like, we'll just go with
all of this.
We'll go with...
Yeah, we're bringing back the 2000s to 2010s.
So, yeah, like, originally, our original line was, like, a
t-shirt, a hoodie, pen light, guitar pick, and a CD
keychain.
And then the other one was...
And they added, like, acrylic sand and acrylic pen light
holder.
But I felt like pen lights are more, like, Asia like idol
concerts type deal, but it's also very, it's also very like,
uh, prevalent in like VTuber concerts, which is why we have
pen lights, but I really didn't want a pen light acrylic
stand.
I want to swap something from that into more of a like a,
uh, Western rock concert or like a, like a rock concert I
can get there.
So, or like something more reminiscent of like, like, uh, I
guess like Western merch instead of like more of an idol
merch.
So I was like, oh, can we swap the acrylic pen light stand
or like a sweat band or the tech deck?
And then we got both.
And I was like, yeah.
I was like, yeah, I got everything I want.
I love the wristband.
I love it because you can tell that it's based off of the...
You guys don't remember it.
This is based off of our logo from the girlfriend cover.
So I'm happy we're able to use...
that as the um as the sweatband i'll give you guys a
close-up too of everything all right so for those you guys
can i think you can order it right now so let me find the
website let me make sure i can find the website real quick i
didn't realize you can already find my merch i bet you guys
just googled dokey dokey rewind time merch didn't you Is
that what you guys did?
Is that how you found it, guys?
Because it's...
I didn't realize it was in Google searches right now.
God.
All right, here.
Here you go, guys.
You guys can...
The stickers aren't up.
Oh, wait, the stickers aren't up.
Yay!
So you have stickers.
stickers are online exclusive by the way so you guys want
the stickers uh you have to get it online and you get two
stickers each there you go oh shit sorry
always the last thing you'll know there we go so yeah i'll
show you guys a little bit like close-ups of all the merch
because i think they're really cool i think they're i think
it's neat all right so the t-shirts uh what i'm happy about
the t-shirt was the fact that uh so this is a t-shirt and um
these are this one is without you dragoons by the way i like
how there's a little hole for me to peek through like hey
like this t-shirt doesn't include you dragoons but don't
worry all the other merch does guys in this version for the
t-shirt um
we wanted to be more like, you know, like a band shirt.
So it's just me and Chibi.
But then like from here, you can see like it's like, you
know, where they have like venue dates and everything.
So it has like all the information about the concert and all
that stuff.
So I thought that was a really nice.
That was something I requested because they were like, how
do you want the t-shirt to look like?
And I wanted to have like a band shirt.
you guys are groupies we had to we had to tell the groupies
to to leave so chibi and i can have our photo shoot um we
didn't add stuff to the cart but can't go into the cart well
technically the store isn't even live yet guys so you guys
you guys hacked the system that's on you you can look but
not buy it's only window shopping for now but you know what
you can buy my streaming tickets please i just want to go
backstage but i want it now
um so a little so i asked i asked to add a little details of
like you know like like you know on the back way would have
like word when it was when where the venue is when the date
of the um damn she's good thank you i have a lot of practice
i have a lot of practice and chilling oh my gosh i love i
think my favorite has to be the cd keychain um let me say
and save the pictures real quick um
Let's see it.
Woo!
Okay, there you go.
So, for the CD keychain.
So, we have, I like the parental advisory for it.
But, it's a little CD case.
And then when you, and then, but you can open, you can open
the inside.
So, on the inside of the CD, then you can spin it, by the
way.
You can spin the CD inside the CD keychain.
So, that's the outside.
open it it looks like this and I thought I was so like that
this was also one of the ideas I had because I you know
because it's like 2000s and 2010s when people still listen
to CDs by the way and um and like physical copies of media
are still around uh yeah no it's so cool I love the I'm so
happy they were able to like bring that idea to life um yeah
what's you guys Oh, yeah, you guys heard what's going on
with Sony?
Which is very on topic.
Was that the word?
Very on topic with what's going on right now.
Where Sony just announced that they are discontinuing
physical copies of games now in the next year or so, right?
Very topical, yeah.
They're slowly weaning off of physical copies.
Sony and Xbox, yeah.
Yankee, thank you for Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
No, I think it was Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Hey, Doki, it's 3DM as I'm typing this.
Just want to say hi, I think it was Super Chat, thank you,
thank you.
Anyway, what else?
And then the fingers, the tech deck.
The fingers skateboard.
This was something I requested as well.
Originally, this was something I brought up, but then when
they were like finalizing merch ID, like the merch lineup,
it wasn't in the lineup.
And I was like, add this back.
I like proposed, I like brain proposed this during like the
brainstorm session on like what merch we want.
And then I saw this didn't make it into the merch lineup.
And I was like, add this into the merch lineup.
merch lineup.
I don't care.
But will GTA 6 be on the PlayStation 4?
Does the PlayStation 4 even have enough memory to host the
GTA 6?
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
Will there be dog shirts?
You know where you can get the dog shirt?
At Anime Expo.
At Nams Cafe.
Where they're hosting all the doky stuff.
So if you are going to the concert and you haven't received
your and you haven't received a notification about your doki
plushie yet, you can pick up your very own little
travel-sized doki at the Noms Cafe booth at Anime Expo that
you can bring to the concert!
Yay!
And also a dog shirt.
You can also buy a dog shirt there, too.
Yes, there is the finger skateboard or a tech deck that you
can buy, and then after the course, post-concert you can i
don't know like do zoomies or something like a post-concert
you can um you can go do some sick wheelies with the other
dragons can i buy a dog you can if you want you can even
adopt a dog too but i need to wait let me message staff real
quick whoops give me second i do a work message real quick
guys i noticed something i want to let them know about it
all right all right anyways stickers now this was something
i requested to be added to the shop but it is an online
exclusive because i felt like um the only way to get the
stickers was from the guitar picks or the cd but the guitar
picks it's like really tiny if you ever have a guitar pick
not that big it's like the size of like i don't know like um
of like a loony or some shit like of a coin so i was just
like well the stickers are so cute i want a way for people
to be able to um buy like a buy like a bigger version uh of
the the cheebies the cheebies too um so yeah so they're i
think they're four inches tall i'm pretty I mean, I'm
reading from the description.
Yeah, it's four inches tall, and it comes with two of each.
So, so it's chance to, like I said, this is an online
exclusive.
So the only way to get it is online, unfortunately.
But it's really cute.
And I'm, and I love how it turned out.
All right, what else?
What else is there?
Oh, yes.
We saved the best for live.
asked are they foil or glass that's a good question that i
cannot answer right now it just says four inch sticker pack
that's all i know i mean i could ask also what kind of
stickers are they
i guess you have to buy the five out true
if you really want to know why don't you buy it
that is so true
all right let me and then we save the best for i think this
one is my favorite piece of merch um out of all of them just
because i felt like it i don't know i just felt like it felt
It feels very on brand And you can also wear it at the con
Like when you buy it You can wear it instantly and stuff
Because you'll be a lot of people there And you might be
sweating And then you can Well look at that We have a sweat
bat We have a little sweat bat That you can use During the
concert guys Like When it's like really If you're like
There's a lot of people And you're And you're feeling it And
the adrenaline and everything And you start sweating Why?
You can use it right now at the concert and go wipe wipe
Yeah, you when you vibe too hard and you know wipe down
Yeah, you use it for at the gym too So yeah, this one is One
this one is my favorite merch out of all of them the tech
tech was a the tech tech was close Was close, but it's
unfortunately second this one's number one um but you can
have your very own wristband of the um of the uh the
girlfriend logo yeah that's why it's a sweat band yeah when
i want all my gym bros to know i rep the click true so
that's that's all the merch also um another thing they want
me to tell you about um is that couple of items uh at the
concert if you're going to there at the venue uh we are
going to be auctioning a actual skate deck so and it will be
signed by all the producers uh and me uh so yeah i'm a
producer so it'll be signed by all the producers of the
concert including my signature there and this It's a
one-to-one item, so only one person gets the item.
Wait, what if it's me?
I want that.
Wait, can it be...
Was only one made?
Because I'm just like, wait, I want it.
That's like a fight me!
Yeah!
Wait!
It's auction.
Dude, that looks...
I like looked at it.
I was like, wait a minute.
I sort of want this too.
She's about to bid competing against the producing.
No, it's ours.
I actually wrote it.
I was like, wait, it's only one main.
Whoever defeats Doki gets it.
Yeah.
Nexi, thank you, and the super chatty.
I need this in my collection.
I need to have the best Doki collection.
Yeah.
I'm the final boss of auctions.
Pull your money today, so she can't have it.
I looked at it, I was like, wait a minute.
Wait, that's pretty sick.
Wait a minute.
This would go so well in my own collection.
Like, Doki, please.
I need this.
I am the number one Doki fan.
Fiction, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We'll go over the super chat soon.
Miss, I took a risk donating $15 in total at the very end of
the month just to chat to you.
And I want to get my money's worth.
Did you get your money's worth?
Fiction, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't worry, I'll write it in not Doki Bird.
Like, can I get another one made just for me?
And then it'll be two of two.
They're like, the full-size skateboard is one of one.
And I'm like, can I get another one made just for me?
And then it'll be two up to...
What do you mean?
You get to share...
I think that raises the value.
You have...
The only other person that owns the skateboard is literally
Dokeybird.
So, I mean, does that not raise the value of the skateboard?
Because you're like, I share the skateboard with Dokeybird.
I...
No.
It's true.
Oh, Val, you gone.
Well, then you have to fight me then for this one-to-one
skateboard.
Yeah.
Then, fine.
You're gonna have to fight me for the bidding war.
I'll have a, I'll have like, you know, like in the, you
know, in auctions, like people from who are not there at the
auction house, they'll send like a rep over there, like a
proxy.
And they'll be like, my client would like to bid.
Wait.
Okay, this is a spoiler stream.
I did write, can I get another one main just for me?
And then it'll be two to two.
And then the guy, one of the producers was like, we wanted
to surprise you.
But yes.
Surprise!
I think...
I think he didn't want me to go on a bidding war against you
guys.
I didn't...
Guys, now it's two of two, guys.
We can be twins.
You ruined it.
Well, then.
Ruined your own surprise.
She can Doki, please Guys, no, I raised the value Because
Guys, I raised the value Because you can own The only other
skateboard That has that Who has it is me So we're twins,
guys We can be twins You have to sign your own Board And
otherwise Why is this not authentic?
The Dokey Green.
Uh, Sim, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Uh, oh, it's new.
The superchat.
Thank you.
My bet's on Nexi.
The, uh, uh, bag.
Thank you.
Would be worth more if we had a skateboard Dokey Bird once.
Nexi, the new superchat.
Thank you.
The real value is going into a bidding war.
I could go so far.
Nexi.
You want I'll, I'll bid on both of them.
None of you guys can have it.
You know what?
You want a bidding war?
I'll have both of them.
That only I will own the two skateboards.
Wait, hang on.
Togey, stop.
Some bite out of spite.
Damn, I'm not.
biblical levels of greed don't test me guys i will go i will
own all the boards one point for each foot no i think some
of legitimately one piece of mercury will never have it's
the one bit of power we can have gang key thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you okay but we also have another
item that will be up for bid and it's basically um but then
it's gonna be harder for you guys to bring home uh so uh
good luck uh but it's basically the k we're gonna make a
standee out of the kv the the key visual so the that visual
you see there so we're gonna have a standee made of the key
visual and then i'll sign it and that will also be auctioned
off so i won't i won't be bidding for that because i don't
know how i'm bringing that home um i don't think guys i
don't think i can bring that back to canada uh do you get it
no that would be the merch yeah that will be the merch that
you get that i won't be able to have because i don't think i
can travel back with that to canada bro buy another ticket
just for the I'll be like, yeah, that's my, that's the,
that's their seat.
I mean, that was that attitude.
Papa Smurf, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Producer is lurking in chat.
Terrified.
Bag, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Would be worth more.
We had skateboard at Dokey once.
I still want it.
What do I just, I'll just like, I'll bid on it like once or
twice just to be like and it'll be like they'll just be like
dokey bird dokey bird bids another dokey bids live the the
price would be like 200 and I'll be like 201 like the bid
goes to 300 300 and not dokey bird bid 301 She's upping the
bid.
So yeah, that's going to be the stuff that's going to be
auctioned off at the concert.
And it's pretty cool.
Oh, that was also my idea.
Because they were saying, like, what ideas I have.
Because apparently last year, Fantastic Reality, they, in
Fantastic Reality, they auctioned off a trophy that they
made uh signed by everyone um so they asked me what ideas do
i have to do something similar because i didn't you know i
mean it would be funny to do another trophy trophy uh just
because of my ocean mark but then i thought like oh i want
to do something more unique that fits more on the theme of
the concert so i was like why don't we just do a a
skateboard like a skate deck because i feel like you know
that's very on theme to the concert itself and uh And I feel
like a lot of people would want it because it's such a
unique type Like it's a unique merch and stuff too So yeah
And you can hang it too You can hang it on the wall and
everything And it's going to be signed by all of us Not just
me but all the producers as well Not the No no I don't think
I think maybe I can ask I might be able to ask Like
Maybe like one of the guest singers To sign it For me as
well, if you guys wanted, but I would, it would just be like
me as well as like all the producers.
So like none of the other guests or the, none of the other
guests or the singers will be signing the board other than
me and the producers.
Game is Skate Doki.
I'm so bad at ice skating in general and skating.
I'm really bad at skating.
That's why, like, I never got into hockey in general.
I don't know why.
I have good hand-eye coordination, but I just have really
fucking bad.
I'm really bad at anything skating related.
I'm so bad at rollerblading.
I'm really bad at ice skating.
I tried skateboarding.
I think I just have bad balance.
Yeah, like, I think I just have, like, bad balance in
general.
And that's why I'm bad at, like, all the skating rules.
related uh sports because I could never get into it yeah I
just have bad balance
I tried practice with tech tech is this yeah when I master
it up with my fingers I'll do my fingers first and then like
slowly work my way up to feet
I don't want to talk about do you guys see the love in that
space drama I don't want to talk about but too much about
it, but that shit is wow.
I was just like, I don't want to talk too much about it,
because I don't want to piss off anybody, because it seems
like a very, very touchy topic, but like, I think it's so
wild to the point that, like, so for those who don't know
what love in Dead Space is, it's like a, it's like a, uh,
Like a gotcha dating simulator, right?
I have never played Love in Deep Space, by the way.
So, I've seen lots of videos about it before.
And it's like, it's like, if you guys ever heard of Mystic
Messenger, I feel like it's very similar to that.
I remember Mystic Messenger only because of I love the intro
song of Mystic Messenger.
But anyway, oh, Love in Deep Space.
Oh, that's what it's called.
um it got so bad with the with is drama even the right word
because i think it's beyond drama now
yeah like i feel like it's beyond just drama what's the word
for it like it's not even it's not even drama anymore it's
wave it became Controversy, yes.
So, controversy has gotten so bad because it just kept
escalating and escalating like every hour that the
government is now involved.
And now, potentially, the game company behind Love and Deep
Space might be shut down.
And because they're being investigated right now.
The Chinese government is now investigating the developers
behind Love and Deep Space to a point where potentially it
could be shut down.
And by the way, this unfolded within like, it was a drama at
first.
It started as drama.
and like the time span between drama to all the way to the
controversy took like three days like it took like three
days for it to escalate all the way to where we're at I just
didn't realize how crazy like how crazy fast and escalated
to the point where the government is involved like I was
like what yeah I literally I was like reading like like the
website got shut down at one point um I read that like the
website got shut down and then when it finally came back up
like the developer website the company behind love and
dispense website and then when it came back up um love and
dispense is no longer on their
And I was like holy shit I was like and then apparently Took
down all the posters Of Of the care like like you know how
like their office is So they're in their office They took
down all the posters of the characters In that game And like
that's how that's how far it's going right now I don't know
what's gonna happen tomorrow I don't know what's gonna
happen tomorrow guys Like, I think it was Super Chat, thank
you, thank you.
Lolly, thank you, the Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
I've heard about that, yeah.
I, you know, I actually almost got sponsored by that game.
I didn't take it because I was too busy at that time, so I
didn't end up playing it.
I think, like, I don't know, every week is a...
You know how I was saying, like, oh, this is Hell Month.
I think, like, every month's been Hell Month this year.
So I never had a chance to track check it out.
I just know like stuff about it only because um only because
like it's a very very popular uh visual novel game I've
heard and I've always seen like I like it would pop up ever
so often on my algorithm.
I never clicked on it because I never click on it doesn't
pop up very like it doesn't pop up often but like like every
like couple of months i would see something about it but now
it's everywhere um
all right let's see
bum bum bum bum bum bum bum sorry i got work message let me
reply to that i'm on crunch hours right now regarding the
birthday event constant the birthday event in general and
everything the
website says an nfc does it take us anywhere when we get
that's a good question that's a good question well then let
me don't care you're gonna answer it it's a good question
all right let me i didn't even know that i think they told
me i didn't all right let's see it it's not fully exactly
guys the shop isn't fully live yet guys so it's a question
that may lack an answer for now for now Oh, it links to my
YouTube channel.
I remember now.
It links to my, yeah, wait, I think wait, they asked me too.
Yeah, they were like, where do you want it to take you?
And I was, I said my YouTube channel.
I just remembered.
It was a while ago when they asked me.
But let me see.
It was my YouTube channel and something else.
But I don't remember.
What?
I had like a light bulb, but I was like, oh, that.
Wait, let's see.
Yeah, my YouTube channel.
I had to make sure.
Yeah, links to there.
There you go.
See, there was an answer.
I'm deleting that.
I'm deleting my message to the producer.
I had to think about it.
I was like, oh, yeah.
That question they asked me two months ago.
LAMP Thank you, Billy.
I'm so funny.
Thank you.
Hey, Doki.
I'm a fan from Snuffy's community.
Really excited to see y'all at the AX events in the next few
days.
Big Doki Project.
Let's go!
Would you mind asking staff if it's okay to bring ranch to
the panel?
I promise to bring a towel to protect the carpet.
Okay, let me ask real quick.
I don't know if I'll get an answer, but I'll ask.
I should have made it to the dokey merch site for the doggy
shirts that's true I quote I could only do one website I
felt like the YouTube channel made the most I have no idea I
think I'm like I would be surprised if you're able to take
it to anime I think you have to bypass security first would
security let you go through because you have to get into
anime expo first to get to the and grieve so um i don't know
if ranch is allowed through adamant expo security because
they might think it they're like where you need ranch for do
you need ranch to make a bomb like is there a bomb in this
ranch is that is that ingredient smuggle ranch we don't this
is what my staff said I'll show you what my staff said.
I sort of had a feeling.
The ranch bomb.
Is there a bomb in this ranch bottle?
Maybe you can do, maybe you can get like ranch packets, you
know, like in McDonald's, you have like ranch sauce in the
packet, maybe that will work.
Just get like a ton of them and then like ask, and then go
to the food court and ask them and they could borrow a
little bottle or something.
and then oh yeah and then go to the food okay what you do is
this is my idea uh this is my idea you i know i'm so i know
it's so get a bunch of ranch packets like those little sauce
packets at wendy's and then go to food court buy uh i don't
know bottle water chug that water down then just start
ripping those packets and like squeezing it into the water
bottle and then a piece of paper and then draw your own
label and be like ranch sauce.
Get some tape and then put it around the water bottle and
then you have your own ranch.
You have your own ranch bottle and there you go.
Joki is enabling this.
She's done this before.
I just figured if you can't a bottle?
I'm pretty sure you can bring packets of ranch.
You can bring travel-sized ranch packets.
Yeah, your DIY ranch bottle.
You can technically buy, you can technically buy like a
thermos at Artist Alley.
So, like, I feel like you could also just instead of buying,
but I feel like it's cheaper to buy a water bottle and just
chugging it, you know?
It's cheaper than buying like a bottle or thermos at the
artist alley because it's like what like a water bottle is
like three dollars or something oh but it's but it's adamant
expo water bottle so it's like ten dollars you're gonna end
up getting our ranch taken away
yeah diy ranch bottle what he donated a hundred dollars i'm
making his money's worth guys i'm just trying to make his
money's worth He wanted to know if he could bring ranch
here.
I'm offering him solutions.
It's our ranch bottle now.
We're going to hear about some ranch incident at AX.
For legal reasons, I had nothing to do with it.
I don't know.
I've never heard anything about ranch.
For legal reasons, this is the first time I've heard about
this incident or any mention about ranch sauce.
if anybody ask
what even is a ranch didn't think of the super chat thank
you thank you what were you where were you during the ranch
flood of 26
uh gaga's thank you the super chat thank you thank you see
I'm not the only one trying to help out this guy literally
was like just buy travel ranch bundles It's not just...
Get him!
He's also part of the problem.
He's in too deep.
We're in too deep, guys.
We have to work together.
We're all complicit.
The wrench expert has logged in.
Now that's a chatter experience.
What are you doing?
you mean we we're all in this together guys oh
yeah i love all the i've been seeing so many uh i've been
seeing so many like world cup memes now my timeline my my
algorithm is now just is world cup uh art and art actually
that's it world cup anime expo and artwork
but let me show you some of my favorites uh i bookmarked
some stuff your grandmother's gonna start showing mean means
now look at this funny mean means
oh yeah i feel so sad because i don't know you guys saw the
holland uh the holland video where he was scared of his own
reflection but it was ai that made me so sad i was like oh
my god that's so funny holland you you know the memes and
then the next day everyone's like it was ai guys it was all
it was all ai and i felt like my reality was shattered i was
like what do you mean ai what do me gss thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you ah
i didn't realize it it's now there is a potential that all
otome otome games might get banned too i forgot about that i
thought it was not it's not just love and d space it might
be all of them might potentially get banned because of the
investigation so everyone's like freaking out right now
yeah that's why i'm saying like the progression the
escalation just didn't stop like it just kept going i feel
like every hour was a new update yeah losing an entire genre
i thought it was crazy that was crazy escalation like i was
like what happened
well well
Where did all my funny may-may's go?
Oh my god, I like too much stuff.
Oh yeah.
Just like...
I fucking hate Haramba.
This is one of my...
I fucking hate...
I love...
I love that we have this stat counter.
Wait, what did Maya move me right now?
This...
I don't want to say maybe Germany deserves to go home.
Maybe I'm not surprised somebody went home.
The German.
Is this a Robbog?
And no, no, say it.
See, if I speak.
Oh, the man, Sharko, thank you, the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
My favorite World Cup meme is Holland Chasing another player
wielding a battle ass I think my favorite Holland meme Of
the running The running picture of Holland Is where he's
like a fighting game character And he does the fucking dash
it What was the score?
You will never guess which country went home If you keep
passing it will work You wouldn't believe which country went
home in the World Cup After looking at this Oh yeah, yeah,
the drive rush Oh,
here's some funny Holland videos Only passes were completed
that day
through this one.
You're right.
If they passed more, if they passed 10 more times, they
would have stayed.
They could have won at all, guys.
They just need 10 more passes.
Have you tried passing to the goal?
That's a good one.
Actually, that's a good one.
Maybe they started passing to the goal.
what other stuff i'm trying to find oh yeah guys guys did
you guys see the brazil versus japan game though i forgot to
show you guys this one oh my god it was crazy
bro the brazil versus japan game that was crazy guys i think
they needed more plays i
What the fuck?
Jesus.
Super Haramba.
Where are you looking at?
Welcome to Haramba.
Is that the league?
What do you mean?
That was the game.
That was literally what how the game looked like during
Japan versus Brazil.
They're using the Jitsu.
Guys, the clone of Jitsu, yes.
I think that's, I think that's like 11 players, right?
That's like 11 players on the field.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, 10,
11.
Yeah.
That's 11 players.
Teams hate this one move.
We talked...
Yeah, that's like...
That's like 11.
And then you skip the...
That's 11 for sure.
Basically, for those who...
Who didn't know, this is...
This is Haramba.
So every time...
Japan every Japan every time Brazil touches a ball I love
this video
Parking the bus This is one of my favorite videos about
Haramba
It's a fucking Oh shit the ball animation Whoops I moved
myself Hello
Oh Welcome to Aramba, for those who don't know.
This is why I really enjoyed the Mexico game a lot.
Because the first half was just all fucking action.
And I was like, they're not passing.
Oh my god.
Like, they're actually...
They're actually shooting the ball.
But how time is it right now?
Is...
Alright, what do you guys want to do?
Alright.
bump bump bump
I see Let me check what I have I have anything Oh yeah by
the way Dad absolutely knows when I'm like I think maybe
when I'm loud When I'm streaming too loud Or like not too
loud but like when I'm like yelling He knows like it's when
I'm streaming hours Because right now I'm like super chill
right now You know I'm like Chill vibing and everything So
dad's not barking But like he knows when I'm like stream
like like streaming streaming and and like literally right
after the Mexico game went back to sleep he said nothing
yeah like when I raised my voice like he would start barking
and then the moment I like in the stream he went back to
sleep and then like said nothing didn't bark or anything and
then and then uh i went uh to do the recording so in matara
and i started like being more loud like talking about stuff
with her and he started barking again and so in the
recording whatever that recording is um in the recording
when it comes out you're gonna hear dad barking
because he's just like pay attention to me streaming right
now.
He's like, silence streaming.
He knows.
He just knows whenever I start, whenever like, I'm in stream
mode.
Because he's like, that's right.
And then I obviously, like, during, I had to do two
recordings of her.
So, like, in between the recordings, I was like, I was like,
you get my bed privilege because I don't let him on the bed
anymore.
Um, ever since he threw up on the bed, I'm...
I don't let him on my bed when he threw up on the first day
on my bed.
So I don't let him on it.
So, um, or like, and then the only times I let him on the
bed is for like very, very special occasions, which is very
rare.
Very rare.
And then so, in between recordings with Matara, he started
barking and I was like, okay, that's it.
special uh you get to have you get to sleep like a king
today and then and then he stopped parking he literally was
like okay he got what he wanted he's like yes my really
comfy bed
it's just like okay he knows he knows he can get what he
wants
so he learned that bullying word
that is a king on king size bed he is i'm weak i'm i have to
work what can i do i have to work
victory is mine he has trained you toky
scrandle i would scrandle if i did if it's not online
because i don't i'm like try like i'm like super careful
when it comes to like showing whatever i have i'm my screen
because i have a lot of stuff on my screen so i was just
like i don't want to leak anything so i always have to like
have like incognito mode and but then i have it like cropped
in the way where uh it doesn't show anything like if it's a
program then like I feel more comfortable, but if it's like
online, I'm like, I'm like, oh, they're
not just personal, they're just work stuff in general.
No, I do use a second browser, but then like, you know, when
you're typing stuff, like stuff shows up too in the browser.
So like, I don't want that to happen as well, especially
like in incognito mode, your history stuff also shows up
too.
So like, incognito mode the autofill yeah it shows up in
incognito mode so I and then also like so I get like super
paranoid I was like I don't know what's gonna show up
we're gonna see a pixel tab with boy love tab guys I have
like I have like all my old bookmark like I've saved like
bookmarks from like 10 years ago too because you know how
like it syncs to your chrome so it's been syncing for my
chrome for 10 years so i've really really old bookmarks like
fan fiction bookmarks that i've bookmarked like i have live
journal on here i like back when live journal was a thing
because all the fan fiction was on live journal before
before everyone moved to archive of our own
oh my god wait do these websites oh my god i have defunct
kelolo art websites because back then before twitter artists
will use will make like custom websites to display their art
and then they'll also have like a hidden link for like the
spicy stuffs but that's hidden in the in the in the website
and then i i have all them bookmarked but they all wait do
they all not exist anymore i'm gonna see i'm gonna see if
any of them are still around oh that's so wait wait one of
them is still around wait this is a fan site focused on the
access powers Italia and other direct works
when was the last updated 2023 oh my god they've never
stopped oh my god i i still have i still have this person's
artwork site for Italia that's how old it is
Did they draw that I was like That was not the main ship.
Oh wait No it was They changed it went from Kelowna To
Italia Wait where was Where's Kelowna Oh my god my google
translate doesn't work on this My google translate doesn't
work on this It's just It's just all Italia Where's my frogs
Oh, there's my frogs.
Oh, there it is.
I found it.
What was my Italia ship?
Prussia.
With everyone.
Just like with everybody.
That was like, okay, I still have in the...
Oh my god, this site is still around too.
Just with everybody.
I see.
Okay.
The good old days.
Um, yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Just saw a bit of your Mexico versus Ecuador, and I'm so
glad I found you.
My algorithms did good, sending me to you.
Can I request your tomato outfit for the next game?
Because tomatoes are Mexicans.
Thank you for the super chat.
Uh, yeah, thank you, thank you.
I don't know which game I'm gonna watch next, honestly.
Um, maybe I'll do another Mexico watch a lot.
Uh, I'm not gonna, uh, I'll be in LA, the Canada versus
Morocco game and unfortunately we might we might lose come
guys we might we might yes I think it might just be um I
don't have to lie for it guys see come without see is just
um Toki, guys, guys, I don't know we can be Morocco, guys.
I don't think,
you gotta believe, Toki.
I think, guys, I think we're, I think this is it, guys.
I think this is where it ends, guys.
Miracles do happen.
We have to believe!
Alright, we'll see what happens on July 4th.
I think what sucks is Canada is the...
From Canada, Mexico, and the US.
Canada has to be the one...
Has to be the first one to go.
It's us first.
Alright, we have the first match.
See, Strong Brothers do not release it.
with Brazil.
You're not, guys, guys, you know, guys, guys, do you think
we're just as good as Brazil, guys?
Do you really?
I mean, come to start with C.
True.
Guys, guys, really?
Do you think we have a chance?
Do you think we're just as good as Brazil, guys?
Really?
Oh, wait.
Whoa, whoa, Joki.
Let's not get too crazy there.
Does she know?
Really, guys?
Who's gonna tell her?
If you're living.
Maybe, guys.
Maybe Brazil will get like 10 red cards and then they'll
have to play the game as five players.
Maybe, that's it.
I figured it out.
As long as Brazil gets five red cards, you'll have to play
with a team of six.
I think, guys, I think that's our chance.
Or no, sorry, Morocco.
As long as Morocco gets five red cards within the first
half, I think we can do it.
I think I think we have a chance
10 red cards and the only player left is the goalie it's
gonna be like the challenge soccer it's like challenge
soccer with a goalie is just blocking like 10 10 billion
shots from seven people surrounding the goal and then one of
them will be offside I did all of them will be offside goals
It goes to penalty.
Yeah.
Guys, we just need 10 red cards.
And the last remaining player has to be the goalie.
And then maybe we have a chance.
Probably the goalie's score.
The goalie gets the goalie kick.
And it goes all the way to the scores into our goal.
You can't offside that.
You can't call offside of the goalie scores.
Okay.
If he clutches a 1v11, he got it.
Well, first off, 10 players have to get a red card.
I think it's crazy that US had two offside goals against...
Where are they playing against?
Against Bosnia.
And then still scored two more goals.
got a red card too.
Yeah, and then also got a red card.
Yeah.
And it's like their main striker.
Apparently it was like what?
It was decided by the system, right?
Not by the ref too.
Yeah, I heard that people were saying the red card was
bullshit.
I was watching it on and off.
I saw them get two goals and I was like, I think that's
enough.
I was like, oh, they got two goals.
I think it's just, I think that's GG's now like i saw both
the shots i i was watching when they scored the two goals
and then when they scored it i literally was like i think
they're gonna they're gonna make it unless i i didn't i
don't know i i know that people like oh but what about the
germany germany versus senegal game you know like like
senegal scored two goals and everyone's like yeah no that
yeah it's over oh it's like belgium sorry belgium versus
senegal and then and then and then on the 90s minute what
was it on the 90 minutes or some shit or 80 minutes like two
more goals got scored from Belgium and then a third goal by
the last 10 minutes or something shit
oh that was crazy because everyone's like oh GG's Seneca
GG's and then suddenly where did those three goals come from
like what happened
yeah that That was wild.
Yeah, I played at night hanging out.
I want to hang out with you guys before I go back to work
hell.
So much stuff to do!
So little time!
I can't believe in my birthdays in three days!
I'm actually spending my birthday in America.
I can't really share my birthday with them.
Oh my god.
At least when I walk out.
I'll be like, they must be seeing, they must be wishing me a
happy birthday.
I can't, the entire country's gonna wish me a happy
birthday, guys.
I see the fireworks, I was like, wow, those are for me.
Business trip to my concert.
What do you mean, business trip?
Wait, oh, wait, my pin meant, oh, yeah, oh, never mind, I
accidentally.
My pin message.
My concert is going to be on my birthday.
Yeah, on those fireworks for me.
Wait, I pinned the wrong message.
Wait, is this not?
Sorry, that's the wrong one.
Is this...
Wait, did I link the wrong one?
Guys, I linked the wrong one.
I did not...
There we go.
It's this one.
the right link.
So that was the old Vintaster line.
This is the right link.
Wait, is the pin one even the right one as well?
I can't see.
Yeah, it is.
The pin one is the right one.
It's alright.
At least the pin message is correct.
That's all that matters.
It's the thought that can... Exactly, exactly.
I'm just hanging out with you guys.
I mean, we could play something.
We'll play something.
here i'll play something short or like something quick so we
do have tomorrow we have a collab with minzo if well it was
it was mostly me playing the game and she'll watch me play i
i know the fears to fathom is a really short game like each
game is super short so i don't know how many of them we're
going to be playing
okay popular new releases What's this?
Is this an idler?
I feel like idlers are making a comeback.
I would love to play...
I'm so sad.
You know, like, all those, like, sorting games?
They're all AI now.
Like, the library...
There's the one with the librarian one that everyone says is
actually, like, really nice...
Like, really...
Not... I want to say fun, but it's just, like...
What's the word?
It's very...
Uh...
I guess But then apparently it's AI And there's a one
There's what There's a supermarket one And that one's also
AI Everything's AI now Yeah, comfy Where the fuck do I play?
Next seating in the super chat Thank you, thank you I'm so
hyped for the collab tomorrow Back seating you is always so
peak Thank you, the super chat Thank you, thank you We're
like, we're like, uh, we're like game, the VTuber game
grumps, but what if we're both Aaron?
We're two flavors of Aaron Hansen.
I don't think either of us are Danny, guys.
I don't think, I don't think either of us match the Danny
vibe.
My personalities are not very Danny coded.
Oh yeah.
Mint gives off Ross vibes.
We're both, we're, we're, I'm Eagle Raptor and Mint's Aaron.
No I'm not, I'm not, Danny's, Dan's, Dan, Danny's so chill.
I can't be that chill guys.
Out of you, John Tron.
I'm pre-controversy, John.
This is why people don't talk about John John anymore.
I am...
I'm on solo John.
There's a clear... I can't...
Yeah.
Oh, that's, yeah.
That's just Josh, right?
Yeah, you're, yeah.
Fair.
What else?
I don't know what to play.
I want to do like one quick game or something.
What do you remember?
It's not jokes, guys.
It's not fans, guys.
I say slash JK at the end.
Every time.
I say slash JK.
Aww.
Oh yeah, my chameleon is so popular now.
Like, it's like the next Among Us.
I think it's a fun game though Wait what if
Wait guys If I buy EA Sports FC 26 Can I run a simulator of
Canada versus Morocco And then we'll see how it goes Like
We'll run We'll run a Canada versus Morocco Just see how it
goes.
Wait, how long?
Is it actually a full 90 minute game?
Can I fast forward it?
I wouldn't say we simping now.
Oh, so you want to get cooked?
Is there a fast forward version?
Like, do I have to watch the full 90 minutes?
Just like the simulation.
We'll make it a 10.
A reduced time.
No, actually, no.
I think gotcha the, yeah, never mind.
I think gotcha the characters.
Pay money to watch.
We don't know that.
We could have a miracle.
Morocco could have 10 players that get a red card.
You don't know that.
Anything is possible.
What if the bar, what is it called?
the tracker thing what's it called what are the fucking
machine the thing that calls the cards for us
bar guys what if the bar somebody hacks the bar and then we
get 10 red cards someone gets into the system uh cause every
player give them a red card and then there's there's only
one player left on the field for morocco what what if guys
anything can happen
one of the grass freezes and then we're playing hockey you
know what if global warming decides to become global cooling
and then And then the grass freezes, and that's home turf
for us.
And then we're skating now, and now it's hockey.
Climate change.
It's like that 2012, the 2012 movie, just suddenly starts
freezing.
Yeah, don't make this bad.
Anything can happen, guys.
Yeah, a day before tomorrow.
Exactly.
We can have a day before tomorrow situation.
And then Canada wins.
Wait, what's the polymarket right now for Canada versus...
Canada versus Morocco.
The polymarket.
Where the fuck's the link to it?
54% odds of...
What is it?
55...
Guys.
Alright, Canada versus Morocco.
55% on Morocco.
And you're like, oh, that means like Canada has like...
Like 40-ish percent, right?
Like...
Draw 28%.
Canada winning...
19%
That's No,
guys $100 on Guys, the whole world thinks we have a 19%
chance of winning Guys Guys So the higher that's I
Guys, I don't understand.
Why don't anyone believe in us?
I have a 19% dream, Doki.
Just gotta keep believing.
And yeah, that's like a four times ROI, Doki.
It's not zero.
It's true.
That's true, it's not zero, guys.
Alright, let's see.
I'm looking at all the other percentages.
What did everyone else do?
This can't be as bad as the others, right?
Don't give me hope.
I like those odds.
Oh my, it's between the World Cup golden boot winners
between Messi versus Embape.
I understand why is we 19 guys come on not even 20 not even
20 percent we're 19 Papa smart we can't even round up for us
we're saying if can the wins I can't game board money thank
you super chat thank you thank you at least it's not zero so
cute and 20 is a little too much think about it 10 red cards
that's i believe we have we have hackers in canada we have
yeah i'm
looking through my games list i have a wish list that i do
Um, but a lot of them are just multiplayer games.
Like me, like, oh, games I want to play with, with people.
There's not, none of them are, like, quick games.
Oh, wait.
Yo, I know what to do.
I, guys, one quick game.
Yes, I know what to do, guys.
I wish I could just simulate this.
though.
I have an idea.
Guys, I have an idea.
I'll show you.
I'll show you all.
Bird, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, I'm still betting on Mexico losing.
This is where you surely can bet your countrymen winning.
Let it ride.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, I have an idea.
I know what we're going to do.
we can do.
I know how we can we can simulate Canada versus Morocco.
Let's get why is it not showing up on screen?
Why is it not showing up?
Oh my god, it's one of those isn't it?
We can do it We'll just import players!
Alright, it's fine.
We're fine.
Pick up window.
Well, we'll do right here.
That looks like it.
Play a badge.
Soccer fans to the most fun.
Bit of the action to ya.
Why, thank you, Sonny.
It's a pleasure indeed to be here with you today covering
backyard soccer.
Playing in today's game are the white all-star oh we can't
leave okay little monsters all right now some of you may be
wondering how i got my name that's this panda versus morocco
dropped me off at the hospital my parents were having tea
their favorite tea is earl gray tea now my surname is i
don't know if the volume is louder louder uh it would be
loud or not everyone to remember my name it's done the
are in to go which one's me join the action down on the
field which one's me though
okay wait all right so there's is this my team
i don't remember i'll play this game guys i we're gonna go
straight in all right the all stars kick off we got this
come on ashley We got this for Canada!
Go!
Yeah!
He picked his spot and tucked it away beautifully.
I told you guys!
We can do this!
The monsters will restart the game.
Alright, go Pablo!
Oh shit, that's not a... that's not a pass.
It's alright.
Kick her!
That's right!
She gets still moved!
Oh, shit.
Stephanie!
Keep dribbling.
Passing the pop, though.
My Canadian man!
Oh, shit.
Ashley!
Please!
Yes!
No!
Ashley, my fellow Canadian!
Shoot it!
Yes!
It's done, Katta!
This is how it's done!
We're so, we're gonna do this, Katta!
We're gonna do this!
Hydration break!
Nice!
Pop!
Scoring!
No!
Offside!
The goalie's out of his box!
Freeze it up!
Okay.
Oh shit.
Offside flag up who who little too aggressive that was a
bullshit call who's off-side me Get over here Pass it's
Ashley.
It was off-side.
No, it's not
What do you mean?
I don't know what you're talking about
Oh, Ashley,
that's it.
Kick the goalie.
Misshandle it.
All right.
I am here doing Haramba.
I just played.
Come on.
Who fucking, who does passes?
Ref!
He tripped me!
Oh my god.
Oh, offside.
The referee is going to be a hardening.
Foul?
Yeah, him.
Him.
What did I do?
I didn't do nothing.
I didn't.
Free kick.
To who?
The little monsters!
Someone's paying off the ref.
Someone's fucking paying off the ref.
Someone hacked the ref, guys.
Alright.
Fill the wall!
Fill the wall, Ashley!
Fettles it.
up.
Find control there.
Wait, freeze it up.
Bring the ball forward.
Oh, foul, foul, gone.
Wait, freeze it up.
Come on, Pablo.
Pablo.
I've always believed in you, Pablo.
Ashley, why did you turn around?
No, no, Ashley, not to shoot Ashley.
Kick her.
It's legal.
Grab her.
She's under control.
It's, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Yes, Pablo!
No!
There's no way.
There's no way I can call the offside.
It's half time.
It's half It's half-time, gang.
And the All-Stars have clinched the lead.
One, zero.
Let's hope they can keep up the pace and see this through to
the end.
Someone's trying to sabotage Gad's game.
A lot of fans feel that their team has won because of the
lead.
But they are forgetting that we still have passed the game
left to play.
The game can easily turn around.
All right, half-time.
The monsters will kick it off.
All right, Pubble, you got this, Pubble.
Pass, Pubble.
Pablo!
Pablo, don't!
Yes!
Pablo pokes it free!
Heads up, play by the defense.
My Ricky.
Oh my god, Ricky.
Ricky, Ricky, Ricky, Ricky.
Just shoot it.
What are you doing, Ricky?
Ricky!
Ricky, I thought you had the ball on you!
Oh no.
Nice.
Okay.
Move forward.
Pass it, Stephanie.
We have got an offside flag.
That's an offside!
We have a substitution for the little monsters.
Oh, yeah, substitute.
Yeah, so we don't need a substitute.
Give me the replay.
That ain't no offside.
The fire is getting pretty good.
I refuse to believe.
Why freeze it up?
Ashley why did you turn around you touched it up with the
ball oh nicely brought under nice Pablo it was offside what
is this riff on where am I off set I am totally on my own
side oh but does it call a time when when they shake me oh
to the goalie get him yes ricky yes offside this offside
this bitch he doesn't know offside oh god
offside this that's right and you say we have a 90% chance
of winning look at this look at this shoot the ball just
shoot it oh my god he actually caught it that's fine just
shoot it that's right shoot it he can't save it again shoot
it again Ricky he can't shoot it he can't save it again fine
just keep shooting oh god wait go Ricky go I'm public and it
it Ashley brings it under control it was off side nice call
when is it not off side bubble brings it under control just
catch it okay that's why Reese is here all right oh my god
stop dancing oh shit oh shit oh shit Damn.
Damn.
Why is my goalie off the net?
Where's my goalie?
Where did my goalie?
Why am I goalie just running?
It's like, why did I freeze it up?
Just, oh no.
Just punch it out.
Just punch it in the corner.
Papa, please, you're so much faster than her.
You're so much faster.
Tripper.
Offside.
I win.
And that's how you know.
Candace.
Go to 2-0 Morocco.
There you go.
What a wonderful game.
Both teams played well, but the better team won.
I love it when there is a happy ending.
Look at that.
And that's how you know.
Kanda is going to beat Morocco.
Guys, in my simulations, we're like 100 off-sides.
Guys, this is my prediction.
Kanda's going to get a 2-0 against Morocco.
Morocco.
The 19% dream.
In my simulation, Canada wins.
There you go.
Look at that.
Oh, wait.
What was my statistics?
Oh, I didn't look at the statistic.
No!
What did the stats say?
When I forgot to look at it.
I still have it here No I'll never know
Alright, betting for Kat and Tio Now we lose We're making
sauce I saw the thing It was through chat Thank you I wanted
to know What my stats were Alright, anyway That's my one
game, guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
That's my one game, guys.
Thank you all for hanging out with me today.
I had a great time just chilling with all of you guys and
yapping and docking.
I wish we played more games today, but like I said, I'm sure
this is hell week right now with all the birthday prep, but
tomorrow, tomorrow there is a collab with Mint.
so we have that at least more at more gaming more games and
stuff um so but i do hope you guys just enjoyed hanging out
with me just talking instead of gaming today i always love
hanging out with you guys and i'm just yapping it off um
anyway as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get
up and move around to get that blood flow and you need stuff
from me head to bed cause you deserve it i'll see you guys
next time everybody bye guys bye time hang out today dragons
bye bye